in the months leading up to a tragic
passing Lisa Marie Presley attended
several events to honor the film Elvis
but what did the King's Daughter really
think of her dad's colorful biopic the
answer may surprise you director baz
luhrmann's Elvis biopic starring Austin
Butler and Tom Hanks reached a silver
screen on June 24 2022 before the
general public got to check it out
however people within the Prezi estate
got in a few sneak screenings early for
instance in early May Priscilla Presley
Elvis's wife from 1967 to 1973 shared
her first reactions to the film
following an advanced screening by
Lerman himself Priscilla explained on
Facebook this story is about Elvis and
Colonel Parker's relationship it is a
true story told brilliantly and
creatively that only baz in his unique
artistic way could have delivered Austin
Butler who played Elvis is outstanding
shortly after Priscilla shared her
thoughts Elvis fans got another Presley
opinion this time from the king of rock
and roll's daughter Lisa Marie who
tragically passed away on January 12
2023 at the age of 54. she also chose to
share her personal review on social
media and thankfully for all involved it
seemed like she was just as impressed by
the film as her mother taking to her
Twitter account on May 14 2022 Lisa
Marie Presley revealed that she too was
blown away by the biopic tweeting let me
tell you that it is nothing short of
spectacular absolutely Exquisite Austin
Butler channeled and embodied My
Father's Heart and Soul beautifully thus
remarkable praise for Butler's acting
considering Presley's real-life
connection speaking to Vogue in April of
2022 Butler recalled how he spent years
teaching himself piano and guitar when
he was younger to the point where his
fingers would bleed but it wasn't just
his musical talent that got him the part
Butler has a heartbreaking real-life
connection with Elvis the deaths of
their mothers which helped him Channel
an emotionally charged and convincing
acting performance as well Butler told
the outlet Elvis's Mama passed away when
he 23 the same as me he told Vogue about
a nightmare he had before auditioning
for Lerman which greatly affected his
approach to playing the king Butler said
to Vogue my mother was alive again but
dying and it felt so fresh and painful I
thought Elvis probably had nights where
he woke up from nightmares like this so
what can I do with that according to
Lemon what results it was a performance
unlike what he had seen from the other
actors who tried out as lemon told Vogue
from the moment I met Austin he was
carrying something of Elvis with him
after dazzling moviegoers at the cinema
Elvis would Garner enough attention to
get some love at the 2023 Golden Globe
awards the musical biopic was up for
three Awards but it only managed to walk
away with a single one Austin Butler won
the Golden Globe for best actor in a
motion picture drama Fang says portrayal
of Elvis Presley but that's not all he
also received plenty more praise from
Lisa Marie Presley prior to his victory
ahead of the ceremony Lisa Marie spoke
with Access Hollywood about Elvis and
the importance of the film to her and
her family well she made it clear how
much it means to her she also reiterated
how well Butler brought her father to
life at the movies she shared he got all
of it
how to describe him but he all of his
mannerisms he absolutely nailed it Lisa
Marie also predicted that we'll be
seeing big things out of Butler in the
coming years she said of Butler just as
good off-screen as he is on amazing such
a sweetheart like a authentic true
sweetheart sadly this would be one of
Lisa Marie Presley's final interviews
seeing as she was hospitalized and
passed away a few days later at least
before her death she got to see Austin
Butler baz lemon and everyone who helped
make Elvis a reality honored for their
hard work and dedication to her father's
biopic a film she happily puts a stamp
of approval on